and thank you for a key organizers boy
workshop so Kevin talk about context
challenge yesterday in more in a graph
theoretic approach today I'm going to
talk about a closely related approach of
called chief theoretic or topological
approached by Sampson and Adam
brandenburger and I'm going to sort of I
guess Sampson has been a you know
lecturing about this approach a lot I
guess oh ok ok then I'm going to remind
you what this approach looks like and
then I will give you a bit of a logical
reflection on this and then i will give
you sort of a bit of new results but
anyways i go go to be yeah let's cut to
the chase so in this area topological
approach we are going to deal with a
context reality as a sort of a matter of
the topology of data in a very general
setting or general formalism so it can
be about the formalism can be about
variables and values of those variables
in general for instance you can talk
about measurements and their outcomes or
in relational databases you can talk
about attributes and data values or if
you apply this to logic you can talk
about sentences and their truth values
so the minimum I mean the basic common
structure formal structure is just the
following so you have we have a set of
variables and then I'm going to add for
each each very variable I'm going to
take a set of values they may intersect
with each other but I'm going to take a
disjoint union of them in this way or
say you can say this is a dependent type
so you're going to take a year dependent
some anyways the point is that you have
two sets set of variable
and set of a year say question answer or
variable value pairs or something like
that so you have two sets now I'm going
to add a topological structure on top of
this and then i'm going to i mean
topology is can be about many things but
there are two aspects i'm going to use a
lot so first aspect is that topology
distinguishes what is a good sort of
continuous section continues what is
continuous and what is not continuous
yeah like this this is a continuous
section that is not on the continuity
breaks breaks down there and so on the
other aspect is that topology tells you
given as sort of a set or space a point
it tells you how you can move rather
around in that space so in this case you
from red from blue to green you have to
pass red point or in here too if you
start from here to go here there you
have to cross a red line and so on so
the topology is about how you can move
around too so there are two aspects I'm
going to use in this formalism so the
first comes in when you observe that
well sometimes you can ask several
questions at once but answers you get
from say physical systems or relational
databases or the model of logic in front
of you may obey certain constraints for
instance if you are sort of measuring
temperature and volume or the gas in
front of you then they you know are in
proportion to each other so the values
must go ad so the values must you know
be correlated we chat with each other or
in logic if you say take those sentences
fine not fight naught naught Phi then
there are truth values maybe untie
correlated and it must be
anti-correlated right so the point ok so
you can also talk about relational
databases and you can talk about say
Samsung abramsky University of Oxford
and so on in the relational database so
the point is that models in front of you
are going to distinguish good and bad
ways of connecting dots so in the first
side I use data you know introduce dots
now you are going to another topology is
going to tell you what is important
model the constraint of the model is
going to tell you what is a good way of
connecting dots what is a bad way of
connecting dots that's as in this so
it's it's it's how the topology comes in
because topology is about distinguish
good and bad ways of connecting sections
that all right ok the next the second
aspect of topology comes in when you
observe the following so query when you
make a query or maybe when you make a
measurement though they are several
major values or I'm sorry variables or
several measurements at the same time
then they are going to form a
measurement context but so those are the
examples we saw but we may not be able
to get to say measure or ask or of those
queries concerning other set of
variables for instance the variable set
V may be too big to you know a query or
deal with feasibly or database schema
may not have a table encompassing all
those attributes envy or in quantum
mechanics this is this is what the
villain was talking about yesterday so
Alice have to have to choose one
measurement from two measurements and
then Bob is going to me how to choose a
one from two measurements he can make
and then those cannot be made at once
those cannot be made up made at once
those can be those can be and so on so
in the end you're going to get those
combinations of sets of measurements
that can be made at once at the same
time now so the point is that the this
you know the family of context of
measurements that can be made at once is
going to form a simplicial complex that
is a download closed family of finite
subset of all the measurements so it
looks like this way or if you look at
this way this is a simplicial
approximation to our circle of the kind
we saw in the previous slides ok so this
these are two topological aspects in the
model now I'm going to define how to
polish core model as just you know
though it's two sets with topologies on
top of each other so formally speaking a
topological model can be defined in two
ways first you can say consider that as
appreciate assigning to each measurement
with each variable you're going to
assign a the set of possible values of
that variable and for each a measure I
mean combination of variables that can
be measured together you are going to
assign the set of good combinations good
ways of connecting dots so in this model
in this particular example I'm going to
throw in all the four possible
combinations meaning that this model
doesn't have any constraint about what
about the possible values of those
variables but on the other hand i'm
going to omit above this context i'm
going to delete this edge meaning that
this model expresses a constraint that
00 cannot be measured at once so if Alex
chooses this measurement and Bob chooses
this measurement then the outcomes the
possible combinations of outcomes they
can observe is 011 011 but not 00
is that all right okay so the same thing
happens here and the similar thing
happens here too so if I les chooses
this Alice make measures this Bob two
measures this then 11 is ruled out
that's how the unit model expresses the
constraint so you can say this is a
pretty assigning all the possible
combinations of values and then you're
going to say it assigns relations blah
blah blah so technically speaking it is
a separated pre-shift but anyway that's
not so important right now Oh or another
way of looking at it is that they are
this one is a another simply show
complex so this is a simplicial complex
over simplicial complex in a certain way
but this is not I mean this is just a
formalism so so far the idea must be in
this picture all right so so yeah okay
this is assigning assigning assigning
but now more important thing is that if
you look at this a topological sort of a
bundle sitting this guy sitting on top
of this guy you can find a what is
called a global section in this space
what I mean this is a sort of a a copy
of downstairs in such a way that every
everywhere this red circle obeys the
constraint above every context so a
definition formerly a global section is
a function from here to here so that you
can go back to the original in the way
everywhere the constraint is satisfied
by that function yeah okay so this is a
easy idea but the point is that this
global section amounts to assignment of
you know values to all the variables
this is global section not just local
section so this is going to assign all
the values to all the variables in a way
consistent with every constraint
minimal yeah so for instance if you look
at this as expressing something about
logic models of logic then global
sections are exactly the models of a
propositional logic class co-promotion
not logic because those global our
global a sections are exactly the
assignment of truth values to all the
sentences in a way consistent to the
laws of logic right so you can say this
consistency of the sentence X is
equivalent to send it to hey X is true
and you're going to see whether that can
extend to some global section or not
that that's what the you know
consistency of that sentence is about
okay but so so yeah okay think of it
this way you may think that hmm so in
the physical context you may think of
this as a state of a physical system for
instance in the case of a a gas in front
of you and you may be able to you may
maybe you are only going to measure
temperature and pressure of that gas but
all the other physical magnitudes are
already assigned in the physicals are
already there in the gas so well it may
seem natural for you to think that okay
so those global sections are the state
of physical systems well okay that's the
assumption is good in classical
mechanics classical physics but not in
quantum mechanics this is exactly what
the contextual et is about so let's see
let's take an example from quantum
mechanics that is that does it that
violates this assumption that is
actually the example I took two or three
slides ago this is a model found by
Lucian hardy and the point well one
point is that sometimes you can see a
global section like that so the idea is
that if Alice chooses this Bob chooses
this and if they observe save this
combination of out
then they can what we can explain the
situation by saying that maybe there was
a global assign mental physical
magnitudes to all the fiscal welcome I
mean values to all the physical
magnitudes and Alice and Bob just you
know observed that but on the other hand
if Alice chooses this Bob chooses this
and observe this combination of values
or outcomes then the point is you cannot
extend this to a global section in a way
consistent to all the constraints in
this area physics so the point is that
as soon as as soon as well ok that's too
quick as soon as they observe this
combination of outcomes that kind of
global explanation is is all the bets
are off you cannot you cannot say there
was a conversate Allison Bob chose this
measurement context and you may want to
say that well the you know measurement
is context independent independent oil
that choice of context there was
physical magnitudes already in the in
the system you may want to do say that
but no because there's no global
assignment of physical I mean values to
those physical magnitudes that are
consistent with all the constraints you
have to say you have to accept that okay
this joint outcomes was essentially in
the dependent on the choice of
measurement context and context charity
so Samson's idea of characterizing
context charity is to use the topology
of data alone and to say that context
charity lies an obstruction to the
extension of this section to a global
section yes
the object in the base there oh yeah
yeah yes yes yes yes yes so when I now I
mean context by a set of measurements
that can be made at once in the physical
context so a0 a0 a1 that would not be a
context right right right right breast
was just a simple Caesar yeah yeah yeah
that's right yes of course um you can
talk about some section on top of this
you know illegal I'm context and yeah I
mean engine yes I'm going to yes i'm
going to use context as valid or no
illegal set of values variables we go in
the sense that they are in the physical
context or in quantum context that those
are the set of those are the sets of
measurements that can be made at once
objects of see yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's right all right so far so good
okay i'm a bit i spending too much time
on this so moreover if you sort of start
thinking of contact jollity this way
then you can think of a even stronger
kind of context reality like this
because this is the model a Tobias
talked about and we discussed in your
talk now anyway this is a correlation
correlation correlation and anti
correlation so hence this is going to
sort of area there's there's no there's
no global section for this model so this
is Ayia even stronger than this case and
it's called a strong context charity so
the point is also so the sorghum is that
the context she ality consists in a
local consistency but global
inconsistency so you know within those
measurement context you can you can be
they obey constraint in a way consistent
to given physical constraints or even
this context and this context a sort of
interact with each other which I'm going
to
talk about later but so this vocal
consistency doesn't entail global
inconsistency because sometimes their
section cannot extend to a global that
is contextual IT anyways so this is a
little small remark so nonlocality in
this picture normal quality is amounts
to ask just a special case of context
reality implemented by using a spatially
separated systems and composing them
together as a contact chirality in that
context would amount to nonlocality but
also there's a probabilistic version of
this as well which who he is going to
talk about that so I'm going to sort of
be quick about that so look at this
model this is not logically contextual
because every section extends to global
but if that happens you can see that
then this is a just a disjunction or
possibility mixture of the global
sections right can you see that pea
that's that's the case if and only if
okay so if you're going to replace that
possibility mixture with the probability
mixture then you get a probability
probabilistic context ality as in bell
nonlocality theorems but I'm going to
skip over so this is a probability
one-half of this yeah global section
this is one half of this section and
then this model is a not contextual but
bell's theorem states that they this
cannot be realized that way but anyway
that's that's a probabilistic part okay
there's one more thing okay so so the
point is that quantum mechanics behaves
weirdly sometimes now but even those
weird paradoxical systems must satisfy
the following condition called no
signaling principle in the followings
which amounts to the following condition
in our setting in this possibility k
meaning that the this model is no
signaling even only if every restriction
of those combinations to smaller
combinations is a surjection world onto
map why does why does it mean no
signaling so let's talk about the
failure of no signaling yeah so here I'm
going to delete this section so that
this is a violation of this formal
condition of law signaling why does it
kind of signals well because in this
case in this case if Alice choose our
say pushes this button Alice can push
this button with this button always
chooses this button and suppose Bob
observes this then if this constraint is
really the case then Bob can infer that
whoa because this is you know up
possible with this one but not with this
one so all this must have push this one
even if Alice and Bob are separated you
know far far away so this is no
signaling and then so it's a kind of a
relativity ish principle but also in a
relational database it's about
consistency among tables so I'm so we
usually take this as part of the yes so
so suppose this is a one table in the
relational database and one relational
database then the this table is going to
say that hey this guy is in this table
is going to say these guys not
restriction I'm sorry what were sorry
yeah yeah yeah yeah so whether this is
in the database or not depends on this
table and this table so those tables are
not going to agree with each other with
spector whether this is a value is in
there yeah I mean a consistency or
coherence maybe at some of course of
course I mean the tables zero is all
strings or something to you that every
string would have to appear in your
table yeah okay yes the inner in
Dustin's yes in that sense I mean it's a
consistency about this guy and this guy
oh yeah anyways double date dependency
less attention yeah I'm going to skip a
yeah those because I don't have time its
but I don't have so using this framework
well so this this framework can be used
as sort of a semantic structure now and
using this as a semantic structure there
is a powerful tools available to sort of
a detect or prove context charity so for
instance go back to this area example
and observe that they are those blue
sections satisfy this equation X plus y
equals more 0 mod 2 and those satisfy
this equation right so going back to
this area this example this model this
model can be perfectly described by
those four sets of equations because
those those are blue satisfy those blue
and this and this satisfy read the
equation so yeah so this model called PR
box satisfies those four equations now I
mean if I mean but those four equations
must entail that if you sum up the
left-hand side and the right hand size
they must be the same
what is entailed by this set of
equations but they cannot be because
well I mean each variable occurs twice
so it cancels out it's zero to the left
but one to the right so they are
inconsistent with each other so the
upshot is that there is no global
assignment consistent with all those
four constraints that is that there's no
global section there's no global section
2 this model that is so this a the
inconsistency of those equations are
going to detect the strong context
charity of the model will prove their
strong context charity of the model now
so and actually this method is going to
subsume all the previously known
examples of strong context reality
argument in quantum mechanics so this is
quite a powerful machinery and also you
can sort of relax the vocabulary then we
can cover many more examples but that's
not quite point today so this is this is
the previous work so today I'm going to
help like I don't know six moment I'm
going to give you one small reflection
about what is going on in this context
reality argument because I think okay so
this is this is the argument observe
note that this inconsistency usually in
logic in consistency means that there is
no load edition model right but it
doesn't mean that here because this
inconsistency doesn't mean that there's
no model satisfying those equations look
there was a PR box satisfying all those
equations or if you put it in say
entailment form the entailment form
doesn't mean that all the models
satisfying the antecedent are going to
satisfy the concept no it's counter
example so the point is that all the
context charity argument we saw is not
so I mean the logical the context of the
argument is not sound with respect to
contextual models well that's that's a
whole point of the argument though I
mean look this is a classical logic and
the classical logic is violated by those
models there boy that's not a classical
model that's the whole point of the
argument but now and so that sort of a
you know that gives rise to the question
that okay so what would be the logic of
those contextual models so they are on
the one hand we have this conventional
global logic for global sections but now
we are in search of a sort of new logic
for contextual models okay so that's
that's the that's the question I'm going
to review in the rest okay so how to how
to proceed how to proceed one
observation to start with is that ok
this is globally sound but not sound
with respect to any contextually locally
sound okay I mean there's a counter
example but if you look up this set of
equations this pair of equations then
this is actually not just globally tell
it but this is locally valid
contextually tell it because this is
going to say that there's no section
above this context
this says that a and B a 0 and b 0 are
correlated and anti-correlated so there
can be no section above this context
that satisfy both of them so the point
is that the point is that the sound
logic of contextual models can be based
on the fact that if you if those
sentences are only talking about
formulas are only talking about you know
context rather than global set of all
the variables then you can still talk
about them I mean valid logic of them
okay so in this is the upshot right
influence within the context is about
local sections therefore they are valid
not just globally but also locally
because they are valid about those
sections but also that this is another
interesting point that local influence
can also go across different contexts in
the following way so compare this set of
equations or say this inference this is
valid I mean as we saw this is
invalidated by this contextual model so
this is only globally valid but now
think of adding one more context to here
so that those three the combination of
three is a context and this is a context
to two I mean adding a challa Carly so
that there you can measure those three
measurements at the same time and
replace let me take this one we just
replacing be one with C then it turns
out that this inference is valid with
rosanna just globally but also locally
for the following reason so you can
decompose this influence as this way so
starting from this part this part those
three formulas are about
this context so this is not just
globally but locally valid if you take
this one then this is not about not just
about this context but also this context
to but now you see this then you can
combine this I'm putting this under the
rug but now combine this one to this one
then those three equations are about
this context again therefore the point
is that we just passed information
locally from this context and then
derive do something about this context
which is about also about this one and
then pass it on to this context starting
from the larger context and smaller
context and larger context again so I
call it I mean it's the same shape as
this look the locomotion of this one so
I call it an interim logic but anyway
that's a few yeah okay all right all
right okay so let's let's let's maybe I
should start wrapping up so so the this
can be done actually this area logic can
be done in general setting using just
regular language but i'm going to work
maybe i should say something about that
too the essence of the this area into am
logic is moving passing information from
a smaller context to larger context at
larger context to smaller context so
there are two operations involved one is
starting from a smaller context and in
bed I mean send a sentence to a larger
context but also you should be able to
come back and that's exactly captured by
existential statement because that's a
left adjoint end this encapsulate all
the only all and only information that
is given here about this one and as it
should also this has to be satisfied
because if a are some sentence is both
about this one and this one then going
back here and coming back here should
to change the meaning of the sentence
that's all so so everything can be done
in the because this is regular logic you
can be modeled in a regular category but
then the point is well okay so it's a
sort of a generality that is useful but
I will be I will talk about sort of a
the rough idea of how their logic goes
so the point is so the logic we we are
going to define syntax logic and
semantics of this inchworm logic as kind
of a prosthetic to a global logic so you
start from a logic and then you
parameterize them into sort of a
fragment into a fragment of them so we
start from the usual language and then
you are going to take each context or
each each ballot I mean not valid
context but the legal context and you're
going to take all the formulas in one
legal context or another was other and
then we call it contextual language so
the you have you start from all the set
of sentences and then you're going to
say hey this is a legal fragment of the
language now so for instance for
instance this is legal this is legal
because they are both about the valley I
mean of the decklid context or in the
simplices in the model but this is not
because this is cannot be in the context
that is jointly measurable so this this
is good this is not and then you're
going to take your going to take a
inchworm fragment of weaker logic as
follows so the first thing is that every
every so you start from a global logic
globallogic you start from a
conventional logic and you take that
when when and inference can be done
within a
context then that's a good influence so
for this is an example but then you are
going to be able to change this good
influence on me and this contextually
good local influence in this way with
with the condition to me without me so I
mean the witness context witnessing this
part and this part may be different
that's how you can start from one
context and move move move in inch one
wise and then you can this is also
moving moving so this is a chain of this
inchworm movement and then that that
gives you this inchworm logic and then
you can sort of define semantics in the
obvious way in as a fragment and then
you get a completeness theorem in a
really parasitic way so let me just wrap
up with the statement so suppose you
have you start with a global logic for
which you can just apply the usual
categorical logical method to get a
classifying or coma or conservative or
canonical model then in that canonical
model everything every completeness
about the inchworm part is satisfied by
that model so you're going to get a
family of completeness theorems in a way
parasitic to the usual categorical
completeness theorem for instance if you
start from a regular logic then the
usual categorical logic gives you a
classifying regular category for your
theory then that the theory if you take
a fragment into one fragment of that
then it is already classifying a model
for your interim logic that's that's how
the completeness goes um I will stop
here I think yeah isn't it good all
right thank you
[Applause]
since this site is not a good question
that that defines that depends on the
formulation but here the elimination in
general is not because you have to take
care of the you have to take care of the
I mean do you think this is cut yeah but
you have to sort of somewhere you have
to take care of the fact that they are
every step is good with in some context
to another it's a that's a question or a
comment it's just purely formerly the
logical describing has looks where I
mean has flavor similar to what you see
in hyper doctrinal treatments of
constraint systems mmm I see yeah yeah
that may I mean so the okay so this a a
parasitic construction is sort of a
indirect way of getting a sort of a
hyper doctrine issue structure for this
logic because you have a different space
and algebras for different context then
you're those are parametrically composed
them together as sort of respecting no
signaling so yes that that sounds quite
similar even though even though you
still have a again so you used to have
to distinguish between global of
validity and the local value HT
oh yeah sure yes um here yeah yeah just
hang on this time
so
here to here okay so look at the set of
variables occurring in here that's all
contained in this context know yeah
therefore this is inference about a
section local section sitting on top of
this context yeah so if this I mean this
means that a 0 and b 0 must be
correlated and these must be correlated
therefore this must be correlated so all
the possible sections sitting on top
will be them must obey that that
influence now once you get that then
this guy is about here right and
moreover this duck guy is also about
here too right so you have to use they
are no signaling but once you do that
then you have eliminated all the
sections even above here that violates
them
yeah yeah propagation yes constraint
propagation one last question trying to
understand what this logic is trying to
do the first part you described about
local consistency and global comm system
courses so what people doing constraint
satisfaction and many of the algorithms
for solving a constraint satisfaction
problem involve constrain propagation
mm-hmm is this logic a the blue theory
of constraint propagation is that what's
going on here that's what I'm trying to
yeah yeah I mean in a way sensitive to
in the influence that is sensitive to
the propagation of constraint because
because you you just write down all the
constraints and ignore the the ignore
the the topology of how the information
is propagated then you can for instance
sometimes delete all the infimum till it
too much information you're going to you
if you add I mean so the point is that
the in this in this model you just write
down all the constraints and just apply
the logic without regard to the topology
of the propagation then you're going to
say no there's I mean this constraint
entails that there can be no model at
all it's straight straight yeah yeah
that's right okay that's that's a good
way of putting it which are globally
consistent oh yes yes nothing
graphically constraint propagation right
that's true that you came in some rules
for coastal a propagation and after
applying their only single possible way
in a bounder number of time hmm right to
something which is stable but not
necessarily in the solution a global
solution that's right so that's that's
what
that exists you still yeah yeah that's
that's this characterization result
about no signaling because I can
characterize no signaling as sort of a
stability under a propagation if there's
no job for an interim to do then the
system is already know signaling so what
once once you apply all the de se into
amlogic to everywhere and if you get a
stable solution then that's going to be
that's going to give you a no signaling
model which may not be classical but
still it is good in some contexts like
quantum or or relational databases and
so on so II yes so this this logic is or
to how to did I ask you a question or so
that's okay yeah so yeah thank you thank
you yep
[Applause]